everybody's serious here welcome to the
very last and final episode of ever hey
bi TCH it's over it's over
light mic drop what angry but worried
we're still very aware of our equipment
ever ever rise of hewn in to find out
why yes
next yeah next week is the first week of
something brand new big change big
happenings because so it's you this if
you missed last week's episode there's a
little bit of info in there something
yeah watch the last question
yeah yeah the comments below say goodbye
to hey B and the first five people who
actually do that gets a picture of
Nikki's but alright Mike
hello welcome back we're gonna talk
about something that you want to hear
about take it away both that's right
this episode is brought to you by Buffy
you can check out their latest product
the breeze it's a comforter made
entirely of a hundred percent eucalyptus
fiber to regulate temperature and keep
you cool and comfortable all night long
sex hot like it's 20% off of your for
$20 off your Buffy comforter visit Buffy
CO and into code b TCH yeah she made me
feel like that's what the buffy is gonna
feel like yeah same thing never feel
alone again let's save it for the actual
ad okay our welcome back b tches we are
here and we are in a new year the wow
that rhymes right okay are we gonna say
with more conviction though we are here
and we are you year
yeah a new year it's a barely a new year
we don't know if the two year it's so
new it's coming in hot
here I'm not queer but I support them
good did you I'm happy to hear that new
year new Jeana you were public
supporting 2020 well so a lot of people
in the new year they form resolutions
and do you guys have that I mean I've
attempted to what would your attempt so
far I attempted that take your brand
though just not not cause weight but you
don't smoke anymore because I was told
by the state it literally was because I
woke up one morning and I tried to smoke
a cigarette and it was the most
disgusting thing ever and I was like oh
my god am i pregnant and then I checked
I was not pregnant so literally my body
just decided all right pictured your
body yeah like maybe cuz you put that
thought in your mind your body and like
you're mine we're working well you
weren't paying attention and the dumbest
thing is my dumb ass actually tried
again like every once in a while like
speaking of New Year's resolutions
that's gonna be my new year resolution
yeah well I want to not get pregnant
Oh oh my god 2020 not pray give me your
pregnancy
yeah okay you get one just give it but
yeah
you're mine I wanna live your dirty talk
to see this is my podcast we're hungover
it's New Year's get over yourself also
I've come in today a hundred percent
natural that's right no I like that well
it's natural its natural that's me
trying to feel confident in my yeah
you're glowing girl I are you know I
mean we I haven't tried to set any New
Year's resolutions yeah I mean I can try
to do them on the podcast right now yeah
both exposure we filmed this before like
the new year so we have time to set our
resolutions however in pretend land we
should have had them set so what are now
like what what's something that you want
next year maybe not to get your car
towed got our cars towed left yeah I've
never been told before but I just bought
my car yesterday so her first thing
happen car she got it - I like I paid
for it the night before but they
delivered it to me yesterday on Friday
and I got [ __ ] towed Friday universe
was like not yet shall not yeah I mean
like you know that's all good I yeah I
actually
okay I know you did long wait let you
guys talk first because I have some
thoughts about New Year's resolutions
where I'm very anti and I have been for
the past couple of years
same I'm with you okay um so I
really set out to have like these
specific New Year's resolutions like I
know I have some friends that will like
list them out and they're like by this
time like they're pretty [ __ ]
organized it'll be like what the first
month I want to reach this the six month
mark I want to reach this and I've never
really been that person it's been more
like for me it's like well I just want
to focus on one [ __ ] goal but I want
it to be big last year for me it was
reconnecting and fixing relationship
with my family so that one's been pretty
decent your sister about overwatch the
other day oh that's tight yeah my sister
yeah she's a great person I [ __ ] I
missed out so long anyway um but then
for this year for me and this was
something also wanted since I got
married I really wanted to focus on just
mom and really hard so with 20 19 it was
like I'm gonna mom really hard I got off
of JK P and then I got off of barbell
and I'm like cool I'm gonna do this
thing but then like I just felt like I
wasn't in my right spot for like a
really long time like I felt like I was
letting myself down and just like kind
of letting people down by like
completely leaving um so I think 2020 is
gonna be one of those where I'm like
okay I really got to stick to this one
path and just really try to fly to have
baby number two softer though tonight
talking about and just be like yeah we
kick-started this by being like I don't
want to be pregnant I don't want to be
towed and I also don't want to be
pregnant and you're like I think
pregnant I'm almost 40 okay wait that
sounds [ __ ] up I'm 36
oh the time dude I forget all the time
when we when we were in the spa I was
like this pain is 27
Oh forgetting like what's happening here
no they all melted yeah thinking about
you naked right now and we're like oh my
hearing I'm 36 is way different than
hearing I'm almost 40 yeah oh yeah I did
see that [ __ ] up I need a [ __ ] I
need to pay attention saved it I'm sorry
I would end I mean the throne [ __ ] out
there but do um yeah God we we need to
do the whole 30 episode too cuz like
what I'm so excited for 30 to 35 I can
do it I'm so you know you can
participate right because you're 30 that
time you'll be 33 so you'll be well it
was a bit wait no is this [ __ ] young
yeah I'm just a baby I'm for my guy site
smirk bone I got years old me girl took
thousand miles on this baby
I [ __ ] love my 30s let's talk about
New Year's resolution
so yeah I'm in the same boat as you do
where I I realized a long time ago
I love goal-setting and stuff but I also
like hate disappointing people including
myself and when I set like resolutions
if I don't hit them maybe it's just my
dad's voice in my head being like how
the [ __ ] did you not hit that one you
know yeah so I just get really down on
myself which is really counter to to the
like it's like counter progressive to
like the goals that I want to hit
because it makes me feel bad it makes me
have low self-esteem and low confidence
so I found I was not only not hitting my
goals when I would do New Year's
resolutions but I would go backwards and
get really sad I felt like I wasn't even
worthy to have the things that I had
already accomplished oh yeah I went deep
man so um starting like a few years ago
I would just set like an overall like
what do I want the feeling of this year
to be like what what's like something
new was a positive change I can make
that like I haven't done before and so
last year was really like I want to
earth yeah 2019 was like I real
want to live 100% my authentic self yeah
what is that like what Who am I to my
core without any sort of like facade or
fakeness cuz a lot of youtubers and like
entertainers in general like there's a
oh here's my entertainment south and
shears my normal self yeah and I don't
like that
I remember getting typecast a lot when I
was starting out as like the ditzy girl
and I hated having to do this character
all the time but then like in my normal
life being me you like that way I really
like what you said about being your
authentic self because it's funny
because that was literally kind of what
my thing was for this year so I I had a
co-worker just about like two weeks ago
she said to me she was kind of drunk and
she was like you know and she's a little
older than me too and she's the one that
trained me and so she kind of told me
one day I really really admire like your
confidence like you have really high
self-esteem and I was like no I don't
[ __ ] do you know you're talking to I
want to die and then I wait a minute and
like I couldn't even finish the sentence
because I realized like wait a minute
like I would die anymore like I love me
like I'm changed now it was like
literally the moment where I realized
that like I had changed and I suddenly I
do have really high self-esteem I do I'm
wearing a [ __ ] shirt that says I am a
rich man oh yeah I'm very sure oh you're
training Gina on dude I have very high
confidence down in it and it comes from
what you said which is what you said
where it's finding your authentic self
because what I found is in the past year
I have been through so many like trials
and tribulations and not only did I come
out of them but I came out on top and it
showed me a lot about myself and how I
function and when you know who you are
nobody can shake that yeah totally
nobody it's like if somebody says you're
[ __ ] stupid and you know that you're
actually pretty smart that it just
washes right off it doesn't do anything
at all to you and I think yeah if you
really embrace you are and you know who
you are your authentic self
it's like you have this shield of armor
and really nothing can penetrate that
and I kind of stumbled upon it this year
and my goal for this year is to really
flesh that out yeah yeah that's [ __ ]
beautiful and I don't know about you but
I had a people-pleaser quality that went
along with like not being 100% my
appendix off but I didn't even realize
was there really like I just always
wanted everyone to feel comfortable and
like you know just wanted wanted
everything to be peaceful and so like it
just was at the expense of my own self I
would kind of like do anything to make
others happy and I think it like it
really ate at me when it would be
something that I sacrificed to like for
myself to like make someone else happy
and then they would you know not return
the favor or whatever yeah and so
instead of resenting other people I had
to like look inside and be like oh this
is a behavior that I can change and like
I can really just nip things in the bud
and stand up for myself and like you
know just like say the things create
boundaries you know that's part all part
of like finding out who your authentic
self is and like living that and I will
say that I did get into like like I
think the universe challenges you like
when you put something out there it's
like oh that's what you want well let's
see if you could handle that and I I got
into like you know different things like
on like on jkp like where I was just
like living my authentic self and like
being like how does this plan like we
could just like talk each other and
stuff and a lot of friends like to do
that then you know it was misread by a
lot of people and instead of bending
over and being like oh my god like I'm
so sorry I'll never do it again I'm like
no you know what this is just a game
that's not people play and like this is
me and maybe it's not for everyone like
it's never gonna be for everyone but
it's that's who I am
take her to leave it yeah and I mean and
that's okay I noticed for me when I
first came to Smosh and I don't know if
like like how many people have found me
from smallish but if you saw when I
joined in 2017 everyone [ __ ] hated me
all of the comments were horrible they
were so insanely mean and I mean part of
that was that I didn't have a lot of
on-camera experience and I was really
just being myself and I could have you
know tightened it up a little bit but
then part of it also was I was the first
female member to
in five years and people didn't like
that change that was put upon me and I
mean for you have to eight or nine
months if you go back on anything it was
just hate hate hate hate hate hate hate
but didn't when I had kind of started
hanging out with JK news I don't [ __ ]
love me it was like a full 180 like yeah
every comment was about me again but in
a nice way you need to find that your
own audience yeah exactly yes you're
it's your audience and it's like you you
don't bend to make other people like you
and cater to this other audience you be
you and then the right audience will
find you yeah exactly that's a hard
lesson to learn especially if you want
to be liked or if you spent like the
most of your childhood not feeling liked
and like yeah that's what you've your
whole life trying to get people to like
you you realize it like yeah people
might like you but they're liking
something that's not greatly the real
you and so I'd much rather have some
people hate me and just accept the ones
that like me really like me yeah and
that's like that's hard yeah I
definitely had a people-pleaser
mentality for the longest time too and
then I had a point where I realized like
being a people pleaser has literally
never done anything for me it has never
done me any favours you know and I just
kind of one day I just kind of stopped
yeah and so that's where people will
[ __ ] up a lot with news resolutions is I
think people don't know or the root of
who they are they don't get to know
themselves so it's hard to set goals and
resolutions if you don't really know who
you are or what you want so they end up
setting goals and resolutions that are
based off of other people's expectations
and other people's standards and you
know on Instagram it's really easy to do
that because you're like constantly
comparing your you know what I really
want this year a good night's sleep and
I'm gonna get help will be Buffy what's
Buffy gonna do for you oh my god Buffy
is gonna give me the most comfortable
sleep of my life let me tell you
something people this I tried to wash my
laundry the other day I went downstairs
and the court there I now need to pay 50
cents more to do my laundry I don't have
those additional quarters so for the
past week I haven't had any betting on
my bed except for my Buffy I've been
wrapped up like a little baby lamb
little baby with taco in my in my well
because I just rolled it over okay I
crab it it is under me it is above me I
am warm but light it is fresh it is
amazing it's Buffy you know
I'm always talking about this because I
love this blanket it's miss oh I want to
get one it's so it's so dull it is
really though yeah that's right
no more night sweats it's softer than
cotton hypoallergenic and it's a hundred
percent plant-based bedding Nikki you
have a buffy don't you I do I [ __ ]
love it I even got my mama Buffy and
she's all about it oh my bad I paid full
price for the Buffy for my mom though
but you know what and you offers a free
trial Oh
so you can try a comforter in your own
bed for free Gina if you don't love it
you can return it at no cost and Gina
for $20 off your own damn Buffy visit
Buffy CO and into the code b TCH that's
code beauty it's $20 off your Buffy
comforter and Buffy CO and you enter to
the code bTW ch-ch-check my goal is to
learn Spanish this year hell yeah I love
that comforter okay so some alternatives
to New Year's resolutions that I have
found helpful is is if you specially if
you are a goal setting person but you
know if you don't hit the goals you feel
bad about yourself instead what I do now
is I kind of look at every area of my
life so cat family home relationship
money finances business whatever a
career and set like ideal bullet points
like what do I want I envision like each
area like what do I want that part to
look like I love that yeah and then each
month you just focus on one like little
house that you think warm to thank you
yeah it's really helpful wait but all
five sectors with a goal each month this
is like military tactics are you that's
how I ever accomplished life
I got my car towed yesterday thank you
it's been 12 years of living in LA never
got a tow before but yeah it's been
really helpful so if let's say you have
a health goal you're like I want to lose
10 pounds or whatever instead of being
like I have to lose 10 pounds I have to
lose 10 pounds cuz then you're just
gonna stress yourself out you're not
gonna lose the 10 pounds instead you're
like okay my ideal size would be this or
whatever yeah like 30 days of cocaine
you're doing it try adderall okay okay
that's or that's an alternative you get
options on the show later so let's say
like January you're like okay January
will be a health month what habits can I
form in health where it's like let's
just drink 64 ounces of water a day
let's get adequate sleep what with
vitamins you do you boo whatever gets
your boat ticket I'm not a judge of
snorting cocaine I would just rub it on
my gums please do not be drugs cocaine
but I've also never got my car towed so
like now yeah so there's a relationship
goal look like for you I mean you guys
are already married that's me I'm like
like a baby this year like it's a whole
year do you have a month so like last
year for example was more date nights so
it was just like and because Steve was
going through a thing where he was
feeling like really shitty about himself
and like his appearance and stuff we
went be this whole makeover video in
2018 um I really wanted to focus on like
when I go to Target or when I'm out
shopping I'm looking at like oh let's
cute for me let's keep for my home but
now I'm like oh what can I get Steve
like what will make him feel better what
kind of clothes will look good on him
cutely operating him into like
everything that I do rather than just
like that's cute that he's so receptive
Bart would be like I don't need the [ __ ]
I'm like you [ __ ] bright dress
is nice though Steve didn't help and he
was talking about it he's like yeah
I didn't know that wives could dress
their husbands until like two years ago
yeah I know every like like I've been
dressing my boyfriend forever I ain't
know that interesting
I guess because my dad always had the
more fashion sense and so my mom never
dressed him so I didn't think about it I
didn't ever thought about keeping Gena
so are there any like areas like that
you would want to focus on no okay I
accidentally become a gold buying a car
yeah they like hey how much your car and
two days later
hey I got a car oh dude I'm sorry can I
just say it for I just have to share my
car sorry I guess this [ __ ] was fire I
went to a dealership sat down they
quoted me at 349 a month for a like a
2019 Honda Civic it's end of the year
I'm like sir buy your cars in November
and December ladies and germs yeah yeah
around the holidays
yeah they have holiday sales like
literally every holiday well they're
trying to get these 2019 is off a lot
and it's always nice you that's right
Gina so what I did I did so I go into
the Steeler ship I get my I get my quote
and I'm like um that's not within my
budget get out and I leave I go online I
put in a request on one of those generic
leasing sites and then suddenly every
Honda dealership in LA starts calling me
and I was like hey I'm at work can you
just email me so I got them to write
down their offers and an email so I was
able to print them or forward the krail
yeah and like forward them to each
dealership until I kept getting in
people against each other yes I said I
got it I did the old Chinese way I
negotiated so midnight in that [ __ ]
yeah sick of you they're just like fine
[ __ ] take it damn yeah they helped me
clean out my car and it gave me a free
car wash thing yeah legit what a boss we
are not their wives they do not want to
hear us for hours talking they really
will I mean maybe I don't know but yeah
I'm just sitting here complaining and
nagging and I'm like I don't want to pay
this I don't want this any better he's
like here's the keys [ __ ] just go oh
yeah yeah he wants to get multiple sales
waste his time ladies want a woman step
all over them her eyes opening I can't
say she's here she's more Vietnamese I
don't understand oh no I only got eleven
and a half hours of sleep last night no
legit like cuz I'm half asian and when I
get drunk we're tired the full asian
comes out yeah I've seen it
yeah I'm half Filipino both oh yeah
Mexican I know you you couldn't talk as
I said hso well another girl for myself
too like okay I want to be I want to be
my authentic self Nikki can you help us
sit yeah I want to do it right now
I mean I'm ill I'm open but Nikki you
gotta do it in such a way that you ask
questions that like everyone watching -
yeah kind of help that's tight dive
inside oh my god group exercise yeah 20
20 I'm not gonna be my authentic self
I'm gonna get my ass home yes I think
Gina yeah I don't think it's fake do you
you said to the Ferrari that wants
expensive rims you've been saying that
we connected you're not a faker make
[ __ ] okay so let's love it everybody
listening right now get out a pen and a
[ __ ] piece of paper and write
down or tell me if you're one of these
ladies on this panel um tell me like
what an overall
like at the end of 2020 what is the
[ __ ] woman you want to see at the end
of that year like rich look like what
how does she know I want a strong
friendship strong family ship family
friendship family she has like all the
friends all the family doesn't
necessarily have to be a lot I just want
like I want strong [ __ ] bond you got
a bench 400 you know I want I I've only
okay you know bring it bring it I want
to be like I just want to be like a
really like successful businesswoman I
love it I love every aspect of it but
you know I'm in a corporate job right
now and I like it I like the stability
of it but I've had so many opportunities
and side projects on the side I think
maybe I want to do my own thing
hell yeah like I want to be I'm gonna be
that boss ass [ __ ] going to my little
meet I see it as you know [ __ ]
working at 7 a.m. from home with my
coffee on my own business like yeah I
want to be like full-throttle working on
my own thing and I don't think I want to
report to anybody anymore
yeah be your own boss yeah taken
everything from me no it was a twitch
streamer for my ears they took
everything
dude the IRS bro if you if y'all know
twitch streamers that are like or look
like they're not making Bank
remember they lose 30% of their tax more
than that if they're in California 50
[ __ ] percent like 45 to 50 percent cuz
we got state taxes we got sales tax we
got income tax we got all the [ __ ]
taxes I saw how much I made last year
was like dope I think one year where I
made like 70 K like my first year
streaming but I didn't make 70 cam in
like 35 god damn yeah ass that Jacek
half okay boss businesswoman oh yeah
you're one of those when I had that
cutter percent say natural this is kind
of embarrassing but Steve always makes
fun of us so if you ever hear this this
is what he's referring to but I was like
yeah I want to be one of those women
where they're walking around they got
lipstick on their coffee cups and the I
feel my goal is Meryl Streep and Devil
Wears Prada yeah which is power that's
first of all Anna Wintour and that's my
idol yeah that's mine I want people to
fear me when I walk into get off [ __ ]
and like those boobs girl yeah and like
throw my coat and someone goes in like
oh [ __ ]
I want my coffee at exactly a hundred
four degrees no less no more where you
don't say anything you just give people
look and they're like oh [ __ ] I'm sorry
about the coffee yeah exactly movies
based on Anna Wintour yeah I'm not about
her because she gets up at 5:00 a.m.
every single morning and plays tennis
and then she goes into work and she
beats everyone's ass and I love that
businesswoman family and relationships
and friendships what about You Gina a
couple things like I said I just want to
go and [ __ ] live out my 30s no one's
here let me get my plastic surgery
travel but then I also and I've already
filled of all your 30s this year yeah 31
I'm gonna [ __ ] cry because you're so
happy you're crackers you have nothing
else left to do okay so I want to do
that
I live your best life just living my
best life to do whatever the [ __ ] I want
right and then just like traveling um
preferably I actually kind of want to
turn my Instagram into like a traveling
okay so like a rebrand yeah yeah um go
come out with my real last name and just
chill no [ __ ] yeah my last name is
Quan she's been adopted I am too she
would come out pigs did [ __ ] Tiger
came out already bigger than you
everybody we've seen your bathroom do
like Gina and I will live there is this
part of my 20 to go in a cupboard in her
house exactly cute and then I also like
so I'm taking care of like my finances a
little bit more like I have my
retirement fund and all that [ __ ]
but I also want to look
- like investing - like and then and
like like franchising or opening up a
business for my parents
so overarching because these are more
that's more like a goal
arching yeah it's like your umbrella
like at the end of the year I want to be
this person you want to be travel [ __ ]
rich with the fake-ass rich yeah travel
[ __ ] yeah more and more countries and
just like like honestly than the year I
want to be able to say I just did where
was like I wanted this here knows dope
yeah because we're having a strong
picture of of what you look like at the
end of the year is gonna really help
throughout the year right to get to that
place so I think people [ __ ] up cuz
they're just looking at the like oh and
you lose 10 pounds no and really like
just who to what person do you want to
be because like I work and I rarely go
out I don't drink I don't do anything
you're boring you want to be less boring
I want to be because I used to be a
while yeah you know go-go dancer I did
all this crazy [ __ ] and then like last
four or five years so I'm like I'm gonna
come down and work and work and work and
I've been working so much I want to die
so now I'm just like oh yeah I can try a
little bit of drinking I'll try that
maybe you should maybe try was like
balance for you yeah it seems I can go
zero to a hundred yes other direction
try this because your I was working I
wanna do whatever the [ __ ] I want on an
island said she doesn't wanna do [ __ ]
right now she's working so maybe about
yeah and you just did my I recently came
home like a victory celebration oh did I
think so work family friends balance
okay so just out there have an overall
idea like an umbrella idea of who you
want to be at the end of the year then
we also have these questions probably at
the bottom of the screen is George
editing work editing we're editing right
now but um so what do you want by year
also can you please send you know your
social security number and bank account
yes yeah can you come I've in MO at the
bottom of the screen I see them all of
our venmo so can you add like filter on
my face it's gonna make my lips look
bigger Manuel cash a big boss pose yeah
but still like authentic we need
nice flag pose I like that $50 minimum
might spill Joe understand I need to pay
for this place deserves you somehow okay
come on yeah yeah it's all gonna hit
your goal okay it's part of it part of
the exercise the goal
I'm not kidding one time I posted my my
Gio's geo poster picture my butt and I
put my cash app in the comments I was
like well since you guys are here and I
just start getting these notifications
like eat daddy that's amazing this is
I'm a rich man they're like I got all
these donations I couldn't afford my
laundry hey we're gonna do a patreon
this year just you know keep that in
mind okay um so okay is here gets
pictures of all of our buttholes Wow
nice but the whole ya know just a bun
hold and the best part is it's
coordinated and separ and arranged by
shade from light to dark we're actually
gonna play a game that's like which
picture is a butthole and which is mouth
yeah mine's pink I bet it is we
discovered that Bo's has the pink nipple
nipples ever yeah you do this in your
mouth that's what a butt little probably
looks pretty as a big lips and we're all
budgets and Gina's just looking at my
chest and she's like you have pink
nipples and I'm like and then I pulled
out my phone immediately night sweetness
guy saw the picture no problem okay so
then when you set like a monthly goal it
could be something that's gonna help you
get there so those are like measurable
steps that you can take so if yours is
businesswoman first step could be hey
what do I need to do to set up
an S corp what do I need to do to learn
about managing like my money or let's
set a budget like an income pay or
income liability ratio I'm like an asset
liability ratio sure money [ __ ]
snapshot yes you'll get the money but
you have to devote work it I know just
push it back a little marking on the
wall how far back you went that day I
like to do habit trackers cuz I'm
freaking duh Nikki you're like you're
I'm a mom you're I'm ready everything
ever wished I was like you're you're
like personality a makes her bed in the
morning dude I just started that three
years ago though I mean I just need
three years ago thirty listing things
out she has like she decorates like a
bullet Journal that shit's cute as [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] do you find it's gonna do
this hey stop you don't I did I haven't
made my bed in months
yeah I don't even on my bed you just got
here Gina you're authentic to the New
World
yeah cat no okay see you're you're one
step closer
what's up closer to be me dog in a car
Wow
can it be like a fluffy white dog use
drivers oh that's powers but I like to
see like the dog in your Honda and
everyone's like is that a [ __ ]
business woman driving with the dogs
holding a dog Whole Foods
seriously little things like that I
remember like walking through free
people you know the store free people
yeah I love it I always walk through
that in my 20s and be like how do people
afford this hell yeah this is crazy
prices I still think that right now me
too quiet I remember like the fur I was
like when I'm able to shop here I'll
know I made it somewhere hell yeah
for the first time I shopped there I was
like holy [ __ ] I'm gonna buy a dress and
free people dress I did got the dress
just guys like memories yeah yeah and
even though I'm like you know it's like
oh like Oh like that's not a big I mean
that's not like a bit like a thing that
should be like I'm a fancy person now
and look at him II I only buy fancy
clothes it was more just like a
milestone for me to be like oh I could
go in the right direction
not that I have to do not that I have to
like spend all my money on clothes every
month to prove to myself that I made it
somewhere but yeah just like a little
mark of progress cuz one thing I never
used to do was celebrate small
milestones and I always saw myself as a
failure because I never celebrated the
small amount milestones but one thing
that really helped me was the app comm
and one year was to get better at
meditating because hard I've asked you
for meditation advice and I did and I
did before before we even knew that this
was a sponsor cuz this is the first time
any of us are hearing that this is a
sponsor yeah I think for years and I
swear to god it really helps especially
if you're one of those people that are
like I'm not good at meditating because
the thing that she teaches you Tamra
love it
because her name Tamra her name's Tamara
yep Tamara love it yeah I'm right okay
she says it in every home she's like I'm
Tamara I love it no but she's like
Canadian or something I don't know but
what about her but anyway she's like
said she has a really calm voice and she
makes it so that you're not pressured
into meditating perfectly because I
think the biggest like the hardest
hurdle about meditating is like thinking
you have to be completely silent and
have no thoughts and like have all this
stuff being perfect every time
and so she really teaches you how to
like be okay with having thoughts come
in and just acknowledging them and
letting them go and really like letting
it be a practice rather than a like
perfect thing that you do every day and
it's not always gonna be good like some
days are gonna be better than other days
but just being able to like recognize
where you're at in that day and like
being okay with it
yeah and it really helped me in like
getting present and also along the lines
of being my most authentic self like
where am I at today and not comparing
myself to where I was yesterday or where
I want to be just who am i today and I
really really like that I never had that
with any other meditating app or any of
the other time I've tried to meditate so
you should try calm it's the number one
app for sleep and relaxation oh it's
really good if you have trouble sleeping
- really I tried a mil meditate but then
like it always says a clear mind and in
my mind there's just a very some it's
always a high-pitched scream
also they have sleep stories which my
favorite I've talked about this before
and I called it adult bedtime story yeah
there was something else
oh yeah I know so what I liked about
them is at least the ones I listen to
they're very visual so instead of like
trying to make you clear your mind
before bed it like distracts your mind
by making you think of like really
pretty visual things and then you just
don't even realize that you drifted off
into a dream about being in a [ __ ]
field of flowers yeah I'm already
falling asleep it's great and also for a
limited time our show listeners can get
25% off a calm premium subscription at
Kham Kham slash b tch that's C alm c om
b tch and it comes with unlimited access
to coms entire library and new content
is added every week and get started
today at Kham Kham slash b tch
that's called comm oh yeah I forgot
they're like they have all different
types of meditations to like dress dude
I just relationship yeah I just found
out that I'm like a [ __ ] hive like a
[ __ ] high anxiety person but you're
gonna say a highway too much like Asian
meditation like we're proud of you just
because we don't hug you doesn't mean we
don't love you
what do you mean B is it's okay to have
an a-minus
fine my mom gonna have to deal with this
1.7 GPA so funny after all of that I
like you know really stressed myself out
about getting a GP perfect GPA you know
just don't matter that's why the goals
are like crazy but well one time I got
straight-up drag all of us she finished
my point but in a brag away all my by
the shirt oh yeah like I didn't even go
to college so it doesn't even matter
that like I got a four point two six or
whatever the [ __ ] it was okay you can
get higher than a fork did you even
matter that I got an A+ in calculus like
Advanced Placement college courses in
the high school years that I'm like
really [ __ ] smart doesn't even matter
guys matter so you're sitting next to a
full straight-up student so what now
Nikki yeah yeah sube and I see the line
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] there's a six in there - yeah no
I don't have tattoos because my body is
a temple
[Laughter]
this is been a spit-roasting each other
people over there
alright so whatever you got down now
just like no like just take it one month
at a time don't think you have to
[ __ ] accomplish and be this person at
the end of the year immediately but just
know it's almost like okay so there's
this analogy where a rocket ship is off
track 90% of the time and they're
constantly having to readjust it to make
sure that they get where they're going
astronauts in case you were wondering
who the day and the rocket ship was Oh
have to continually readjust and make
sure that they're going so that they are
going the right way so that they end up
where they want to be this is kind of
the same way with goals and like where
you like knowing where you want to be as
a person and then each month like making
those tiny adjustments being like okay
where did I get off track for the from
this person we're can I get back on
track what are some habits that I can
incorporate this month that are easy not
stressful not something that's like
crazy I have to lose this amount of
weight now but just like little things
like I'm gonna eat a salad instead of a
sandwich at lunch or whatever it is I
don't know what it is for everybody but
but just as those little progress steps
and those things you can measure and
then you can celebrate like when you did
those like hooray it shows the right
option today where I chose a more
positive option and potato salad stay so
I want to celebrate there you go five
lines of code you know everything
balances out I'm wondering if this will
help we so we've envisioned like who we
think we are a Tron December end of the
year and now I'm trying to kind of just
work backwards from that and I'm like
okay well Who am I gonna be in July or
June so I'd be 30 that's oh [ __ ] you
know I'm gonna be 31 if you can't wait
for that party if you're like a plastic
surgery made and that travels a lot by
June how many trips will you have taken
comments plastic surgery will you have
taken cuz like we don't want to be at
crunch time in December trying to become
this person yeah hahaha
Sheena's crunching it all around curse
for the month of streaming she is that
person your Foley's [ __ ] hard though
I don't blame
you have a time management goal this
don't stress yourself out don't even
make excuses when I show up late I just
tell people like oh I'm sorry I'm late
it's because of Who I am as a person no
way dude you've changed a lot you
changed a while I used to be a lot worse
geo knows god no you're killing that
sure yeah you should celebrate that I
mean really by sleeping in yeah so I
think that if that works for you Beau's
like having a timeline and all that
stuff if that's what really gets you
motivated you should definitely do it
some people feel too much pressure by
being like where should I be by July oh
my god I haven't met that mark yet oh my
god what can I do
yeah so making like little easy gentle
habit changes per month might work
better for those types of people need to
make $100,000 by March oh [ __ ] can you
start doing today that can work towards
that is it right right for this episode
on beyond my laptop I'll figure it out
Celgene of cocaine slinging drugs what
I've always been a law-abiding citizen
but I'm a I'm thinking about it more
than ever I was like I shouldn't get a
car because what if I accidentally hit
somebody and then I go to jail for
manslaughter and like all of my goals
like everything to be hardly yeah
everything does need to be hardline
Nikki needs to be written if it's gonna
be done my dad for like two seconds I
was like okay very much I'm very much a
doer if I if I if I write it down it's
done yeah like I'm like very much a doer
I would say like 70% of the things I say
I'm going to do I do
like there are some things that fall off
or sometimes I'll realize oh maybe this
isn't the best time or this isn't as
good of an idea as I thought but like if
it works like I do it and it gets done
so that's why I'm very big on setting
goals and timelines for myself because I
I'm like a problem solver I'm like okay
this is what I want how do I get it and
how do I get it within this time period
you ready to get fresh
to the meal the meal a milk delivery
system I love it cuz it gets delivered
straight to your home yeah and it is you
don't even have to be there
I don't like changing out of my pajamas
No then you don't have to Nikki you
could step in your steak that's stinky
I'm pretty sure they are just a little
okay worry about it because hellofresh
delivers pre-measured ingredients to
your house make meals that you can cook
in like 30 minutes and they're so
delicious they're so good five-star
meals and the menus constantly rotating
so you have a chef that's curating all
these meals for you and every single
month it's a whole new set of meals if
you're like me and you got tired of the
same old dang thing then you don't have
to eat the same old dang thing anymore
and you don't got to go to the grocery
store anymore because we're all lazy and
you can also add extra meals to your
weekly order to change delivery days
food preferences at skip a week whenever
you need oh yeah baby guess I get how
many meals do I get give me give me give
me the fries I don't know should I be
shooting down not one no not six five
six not eight I'm like one day's worth
of food for me hello fresh pie gonna
hello fresh comm /bt ch9
and using the code b-tch nine again get
how many nine how do you say well how do
you say no in German yeah that's what
you get that's what you get by going to
hello fresh comm / b TCH 9 and then
using the code BTC aged 9 and if you are
German we're not saying none we're
saying 9 learn English and then we know
or say so yeah it's interesting because
you and I are very similar and then very
different so we have like the similar
tastes and goals and all that stuff I'm
very much a goal setter too but I found
that I
have incredibly low self-esteem if I
didn't hit those goals so what instead I
do is I create those goals still have a
timeline still have that stuff but in
the inner rim like what I used to do was
have to do lists to do those to-do lists
and I would have daily to-do lists and
every day I wouldn't get all of those
things done and I would feel like a
[ __ ] failure every single day and
that [ __ ] adds up so instead what I do
now is I I've marked down everything I
need to do for the month and then like
for the week and what I found was when I
put it a to-do list for the week is I
would end up getting most of those
things done by Monday or Tuesday but
when I said hey on Monday I have to do
all of this and then I didn't get that
done it'd be really discouraging and
Tuesday I'm like I already [ __ ] up
Monday I already have to catch up on
Monday stuff I'm already behind and I
always felt like I was playing catch-up
and then when I wouldn't hit my goal I'm
like of course I didn't hit it because
I'm always [ __ ] behind so yeah it was
just like the different ways of going
about it is I'd set the standards and
goals low and then I called a [ __ ]
surprise every time no great bad way but
like it still happened you works for you
though like look at you you got like
this whole empire
I'm the travel my boat working this is
funny and when we're when we're kind of
having like business conversations and
stuff I'll be like guys we need to do
this cuz I'm like very excited I'm very
like on it and like I said like a doer
and Nikki will be like ok bosz let's
let's chill out let's slow down for a
second but and you saying all this
it makes sense to me because we both get
things done but while you're making Liz
I've already picked up the phone you
know like I don't write it down I'm just
like let's [ __ ] get honest you're
like a get-up-and-go person and like
let's play this and then like commit and
be like ok ready and then ya know I'm
already on step 2 yeah like I think it
works for me and then your way works for
you and like that's also why I think
it's so dope that like everyone can find
a little bit of themselves and learn
from each person that you're with
I've done it your way before and then I
[ __ ] up like I shouldn't have made
that move so fast
I just do now I'm committed to this
thing and I signed a legal form and like
I just watch it yeah so I was just
trying to get [ __ ] done like I've gotten
sued before I've signed up for like
scammy things before by accident
thinking that I was just like all my
pathway goals you know and so now I'm
like okay let's just take that
enthusiasm and then research the best
possible option and then all [ __ ] boat
steams steamboats ahead I don't know
where I really want to hear like how you
like kind of function with these things
but I do also want to like throw out
there and this is something that is
interesting and I like I put myself out
there so much in this podcast that I'm
like should I even say this but maybe
somebody else good like gets a I
actually use two of my bad kind of
faults as a string one I have a very
addictive personality and like not like
you know like I'm just doing substance
abuse 24/7 addiction itself is the
inability to self-regulate with
anticipation of reward which is why I'm
a go-getter and so that can be a bad
thing if you're like oh I want to be
drunk so I can't keep myself from
drinking I want that reward but I want
this reward so I just kind of impulse do
it and I've taken this addiction kind of
and made it into a strength in my waking
life okay on top of that I have very
high anxiety so I use my anxiety to look
3 months ahead of this impulsive
decision and run through every bad thing
that could happen very quickly and then
I decide all right let's do it
see that's the thing we have in common
high anxiety that makes you look through
every possible pitfalls you could
achieve your goal and you go through
very quickly because you're like I can
run through everything that can happen
in 3 months it's possibly bad in like
two minutes yeah absolutely
yeah that's I wish I [ __ ] [ __ ] had
this podcast sooner cuz I didn't even
realize it i was a high anxiety person
and like i didn't realize that i needed
to look at things ahead before i [ __ ]
panic and do the stupidest [ __ ] ever
yeah well how do you get things done
like if you got set of gold that you
know needs to get done so if your goals
like relationships friendships and
family like what are what would be like
some of your monthly goals um so i would
look like
yeah I don't even know I'm learning how
to do that I don't know what the [ __ ] I
[ __ ]
um but usually no like so for me like it
takes I'm like an extreme learner it
takes me falling flat on my face and
[ __ ] up really hard sometimes for me
to be like oh [ __ ] like this is where I
[ __ ] up and like having to stare at
that and and really pay attention to
that and like try to understand how I
[ __ ] up and then going okay I don't
like this about myself what can I do to
learn from this and not repeat the same
[ __ ] mistake that's great um so yeah
like recently like I just did this huge
[ __ ] mess in my life and through that
I was like [ __ ] this is a less than any
learner learn from that so I'm gonna go
to therapy and see why this happened I'm
gonna go and sign up for seminars just
to hear other schools of thought so so
really mature because a lot of people
would be like uh so this [ __ ] a bad
day yeah it was their fault like or
whoever yeah ever happened like it was
[ __ ] not me but to like look inside
yourself and be like where can I take
responsibility what can I do better to
evolve so that I I cannot put myself in
this position yeah I mean I'm I try not
to like I just I guess I don't see a
point in blaming others cuz it's like I
have to live in my own head like I have
to live with whatever decision so it's
like how do I not feel this way or how
do I not make other people feel bad or
whatever so just kind of owning that and
being like okay I can only work on
myself and just kind of fixing that so
it's like if something bad happens it's
like you recognize it and you're like
okay let me let me fix this and let me
turn it into a lesson absolutely change
absolutely evolving tell you how many
people right now even in my own life
online I see this a lot with the victim
mentality of like well some people
number how bad things happen to them and
I just how bad things happen to me and
some people have are the hammers and
some people are the have-nots and I'm I
have not and that's why everything bad
happens to me it's not my fault
nothing's my fault
I'm victim oh yeah and like it sucks
yeah because like know about things
happen to [ __ ]
everyone yeah and you can't like justify
your pain being greater than someone
else's pain because you don't know other
people's right absolutely people say
that like oh well you shouldn't be
crying because other people have it is
worse that's right yeah
because that's like saying well you
shouldn't be happy because someone else
out there has just won a billion dollars
so they're happy yeah like that was like
I was it was I was like dude are you
doing you know like cuz they were like
stealing money and [ __ ] oh no wrong with
you you have a loving family and then
they just go okay yeah you know what
you're right I'm a bad person
I'm terrible and like I don't deserve
these things cuz he was trying to like
yeah victimize so I got in his face I
was like quit being a little [ __ ]
[ __ ] yourself [ __ ] up and be better off
all this [ __ ] yeah you know man ever
woman up yeah exactly but I'm a big
advocate of like therapy like I said
yeah yeah I think everyone should go to
its if you're gonna upkeep like your
physical like you know you go to
checkups and stuff you should I
I genuinely believe that emotional
wounds it can be are no different than
physical wounds like a screen-reader
yeah yeah it's different like honestly
like it sounds crazy but like if I were
to like break like I don't wanna say
break my are but sprained my ankle or go
through a major depression for a month
that major depression hurts it really
really hurts more and I'm like yeah any
tears that people can't see yes and you
might even be hurting other people
around you yeah this with your sprained
ankle it's just you and you contain it
yeah and you and you work through that
but with your sprained ankle you go to
the doctor so for a mental you know a
mental upset or hiccup or or just major
depression going through go to therapy
and I feel like everyone should if there
is like just any emotional or mental
scoring in fact I think it might even be
a joke to cake start the new year with
therapy yeah yeah it's like everyone out
there needs to if you haven't already
you need to go see a therapist dude take
like things are getting to know yourself
even if you don't think there's anything
wrong with you right
something wrong and that's okay maybe
like just for myself January February to
really talk it out with somebody maybe
do like six weeks and kickstart your
year
fresh clean I'm feeling emotionally
stable even just to understand how you
work like how geo was saying she didn't
know she was a high anxiety perso clue
like just getting to know like oh I'm a
person that likes things to be this way
or like that functions the best with
everything being not pressure and less
stressful knowing that I'll get there or
like I'll trust in like my abilities to
accomplish this yeah like imagine
starting your year off with in the span
of like a month and some change like cuz
therapy is about 45 minutes to an hour
with six hours of self work you know
we're talking through it with somebody
clearing out your space like you know
clearing out your mental space from all
of 2019 because in 2019 what the [ __ ]
does happen y'all think I was a
[ __ ] it's like every three years
for me yeah yeah me too dude hey yeah
like 2016 was a [ __ ] fun I hated 22
me too your brain is a desk and it's
like we opened our doors like I got my
first job at the same exact here I don't
wreck this [ __ ] man there's like a
honestly a timeline in my head but I
know that's a weird thing that not
everybody has like I have like exact
months in danger you are dude I don't
know what it's useful for argument true
but then it's me against them and then
it's like no one wins
okay wins unless there's a video of it
which has only happened like twice I
quoted the exact conversation that a
savant is someone who's like they might
be um
mentally on the spectrum on the spectrum
but they have a part of them that's
extremely high functioning like you
could be autistic but they have a super
photographic memory and so they'll like
there's this one guy who flew over a
city in a helicopter once and then he
went home and drew the whole intensity
oh my god extremely until like a trained
man's they try a piano for the first
time and they can play like yeah
classical pieces that crazy that your
brain is capable of that should and I
can't do I can't even remember what I
did yesterday to myself the other day
what are you also no strong almost I
know I know that you guys know that
we're filming this a little bit early
but when this comes out it'll be like
end of December what are you guys gonna
do after Christmas can you kind of oh oh
yeah both very early January tell us in
the comments what date it is you guys oh
what's your point my point is well I'm
gonna ask you guys like what are you
guys gonna do to decompress between
Christmas in the new year
there's about five or six days there and
what is this decompression what weird
because like the day after Christmas and
before New Year's those days are [ __ ]
weird so weird like they don't even know
do you even exist during that time one
part of my timeline is missing like
every year it's like I don't know what
happened that week yeah am I still
having meat sweats from dinner like am i
right like am I still pour some sweats
Jesus and then you expect me to pull
myself together for New Year's and look
great at a party and have a New Year's
kiss when I was just sweating out all
the greasiest oh [ __ ] it I don't
understand what I do between those days
I do all over this year have a law
spot a plan a bath from those meat sweat
yeah just just bathing my seen it out oh
god there's like the small that I go to
it's like you got a whole room to you so
to get a massage
and they they soak your feet massage
that and then you get to take a bath and
then they serve you sugar pay me to do
okay I want to go cuz I've literally
been trying to look for a place that
lets you take a bath after that like
yeah where you just soak my doesn't work
that's one of my goals this year I'm
like a spa caught us here you are dude I
love it
facial person because of you cuz every
other day she's like she's like videos
the whole thing on her stories its and I
just watched I just watch like four
hours a night and oh now it's going on
in the esthetician it's like ya know
what she said and she was like I guess
we're doing I just watch it I watched
Tina's get massaged face get massaged
more than I've ever seen anything else
oh the gold like just make my weight of
Greece like cucumber water shake like
instead of spas in Koreatown it's like
spas in Bora Bora supposed to answer
your question um mom I'm actually
because the goal is family and all that
I'm gonna go to a tree I'm gonna take a
trip with my little sister
we may never come back no we're should I
do like a big bear trip just keep it
local
yeah do the exams oh my god what did I
[ __ ] miss name this big batch with
before I don't know dude I've just I
haven't been in the [ __ ] right
mindset but yeah huh you guys are just
gonna be locked up in a cabin again yeah
we are yeah
favor yeah for sure can you like wooden
it's fresh snow like okay disappears big
old coat yeah can you wear a coat
[Music]
because you know they do that to puppies
and I just want to do that to your kids
I won't body set up a [ __ ] into the
snow yeah I'll try to do that okay so
ending thoughts on news resolution don't
get pregnant except for Nikki I'm not
alright unless you're this over here
yeah unless you're on the ends of the
tables oh right right yeah bread I want
to have babies they want to have the man
butter smeared on this hybrid achieve
your dreams do it big or go home take it
nice and slow and don't freak out if you
don't get it ya have an idea of what you
want and then have baby steps and then
trust yourself and then celebrate it
celebrate when you achieve that take
your Baba steps alright and also shout
out to our sponsors Buffy you can check
out their latest product product the
breeze it is a comforter made entirely
from 100% eucalyptus fiber to regulate
temperature and keep you cool and
comfortable all night long for 20% off
$20 off your Buffy comforter visit Buffy
CO and enter b-tch and also check out
the calm app you could go to calm calm
TCH just feel like we should have
thought this through get 25% off come
home let us know by Twitter plenty it's
a whole last new decade whoa